one of the tools you will very
frequently use in consulting and
many other professional roads as well is
excel though from my experience having
worked in consulting at mckinsey for six
years and having worked with lots of
clients from lots of corporations
many people really struggle to work
properly in excel
and especially to format their
worksheets in a proper way
so this is what we're going to discuss
today i will show you how you can format
your sheets in a way that they look
professional
i'll show you a couple of tips and
tricks that i picked over time how you
can quickly
in a nice way make sure that your sheets
look proper and nice and good so welcome
to another coffee break here on my
channel firm learning
my name is heinrich and on my channel i
want to help you to become
successful in the first years of your
career so today we're going to tackle
this topic in the following way
first i will share a couple of general
remarks and observations
why it is indeed important to format
your sheets in a decent way
and then i will show you here on my
screen on the pc some practical tips
what you can actually do
to format your sheets in a pragmatic way
so let's start why is it even necessary
to format your sheets well first it just
helps to bring the key messages across
an ill-formatted sheet would be much
more difficult for yourself or for your
clients to orientate yourself in the
data it's just
less accessible less intuitive to look
at but the second reason is that it just
helps with the look and feel with the
end product quality of the sheets that
you produce and indeed in professional
services
every single document every single sheet
that you send out to a client will just
be expected to meet a higher level of
quality than maybe what would be okay
internally in the client organization
that you work for many clients walk
around with the expectation that what
you deliver as a bcg consultant as a
bank consultant
is just on a higher level just meet
quality standards which are higher than
the standards that they hold themselves
accountable for and indeed many
consulting firms have internalized that
so most project leads most partners
will hold you accountable that you
indeed deliver results to the size
levels so that being said let me share a
couple of practical things what you can
do
to just improve the formatting improve
the look and feel of your sheets
so let's just look at this random file
let's assume now we want to work with it
format it in a proper way to make it
client already and indeed if you look at
this it looks
quite messy it for sure is not the way
how it should be if you send something
like this to a client and let's just
look at what we see here so this
apparently is merchandise from different
seasons so for instance from an apparel
company with the season code the
supplier code and then the quantity and
the purchase price that is available
here
so let's get started and the first thing
i notice is here that the title of this
file copy of book one
this is not great right you should never
send a file with such a title so let's
look into it and indeed save it in the
proper way
so usually you go with something like
this so the date so it start with the
year
then the month then the day and maybe
then something like
merchandise overview 2021
version one if we just start doing this
so this could be one way and then also
notice here this one book so this is
also always really something that you
would like to name it a proper way
so for instance something like
merchandise overview to make it
consistent
so let's start let's continue by looking
into this so here you see a mess of
different
font sizes different font types and so
on and so forth
so again this doesn't look the way it
should
so that's all standardize this make it
the same
font size make it the same font type
so at least this is not all in the same
style then one little thing that i also
like to do is
always to insert a little column here to
the left and then the buff
and then we make this a little bit
smaller
just quite a little bit of distance this
just in my experience gives it a nice
and clean look
here i don't think we need this
underline and then here also look at
this title this is like a long
messy title so again one thing that i
often like to do is to have a main title
and then
a subtitle so let's potentially call
this
something like merchandise
overview as the main title and then we
can call it
as a subtitle and just to save this
season 2020 and 2021 report
power bi then we can delete this
this might potentially be bolded now
let's make sure that here all the
columns are of
proper size to space it out something
like this next one to do the borders so
here what i like to do is
always to give the borders here to the
main data but not necessarily to the
rest so we do something like this and
now to make it a bit
look better here you go on view and then
you take away
the grid lines my experience really is
if you take away the grid lines
it all looks a bit cleaner now here you
go for
a dark color something like this dark
blue
and then here the white and then you
could potentially also
bold this now i would also like to
reduce the distance a little bit
now next thing we can do is ready to
freeze the paints because now currently
if i'm scrolling i'm not seeing the
headers anymore
so you click here view freeze panes
freeze panes
that this this thing here above is fixed
this also makes it look quite nice much
better
so let's make sure that all these number
formats are clean as well so you see
that this is in some weird way that this
is centered even though this should be
aligned to the right so let's just use
here the
format painter to make sure that this is
all set up in a
proper way now you can see that this is
an id so i would be fine with that i
would now
continue to format this though the
quantity here it would always be good
to have some separators right for all
the thousand
so let's do that now we can see that
this is done and here for the purchase
price for sure this is something we
would like to do as well
so here now let's assume we know that
this is euro
then it definitely would be nice to also
include this in such an accounting
format with the euro sign
so if we now open the old one and now
compare it to the new one i hope that
you agree that now the new one looks
nicer and cleaner to what you had before
and indeed this really is quick right
now
even with explaining it it just took me
a couple of minutes and usually of
course it's even faster
if you just do it on your own now just
in addition to that let's imagine have a
bit of a more
complex layout with maybe different
types of tables next to each other's and
you'd like to do that as well but here
are two tips
so my general recommendation would be
that if you know start building
different tables
rather build them one under the other
instead of now
adding them here to the right this is
just the standard way of modeling
especially if you have more complex
tables with maybe times
here in the columns then it's always
nicer cleaner to do it
from top to bottom than from left to
right because then you potentially for
instance
could also use the same date fields than
throughout the table for different lines
again there might be some
exceptions to that especially if you
make dashboards for instance then it
might make sense
to do it in a different way and here
indeed if you would like to learn more
about that i once made a distinct video
with a couple of tips on how you can
build
quite powerful and easy dashboards in
excel so i will link it somewhere above
here if you would like to learn more
about that
but now back to this because indeed a
few you would have different types of
tables one after the other
so how would you do that right and let's
imagine we might have even more so here
i would probably do it
is i do it exactly like this right so i
just here then copy the the title of
course this might also be now a
different title and then i would
leave like one lane distance and then
probably also make this distance a
little bit
shorter and by that now you could build
all kinds of stuff one after or one
below the other
and then keep such a nice clean look for
all of this to keep going
now let me end with an additional little
formatting convention and this is
especially important
if you're now working with more complex
files more complex models because indeed
usually it's important also with colors
distinguish the input
cells from the output or the calculated
sets so let's imagine now we would like
to calculate the price
per unit just here to make a basic
example
so now probably what we would like to do
is just to format
this over here just to have it in the
same way now we would calculate that by
dividing the total purchase price by the
units
so just like this okay and now what we
would love to do is as you can see that
this is now a calculated field
and now not really an input field right
where we just input the raw data and
here one convention is to color
calculated fields
in a dark blue something like this for
instance so here now on first side you
see that
the black cells are cells that you hard
copy that you hard input
and then the blue cells are calculated
once so again this just really helps if
you have a more complex
larger model to really understand what
and all the inputs what are the cells
that you
hard coded hard typed into it what are
all the output sales which probably you
shouldn't not directly manipulate but
rather their value is derived
from the value of some other sets and
again if you'd like to learn more i have
more videos like this on excel for
people working in professional services
i will link a playlist somewhere above
here where you find
all the videos that i currently have on
my channel and if you would like to see
more content like this subscribe
because on my channel i will create more
videos on excel in the future as well
so now i would love to hear from you do
you have any little tips and tricks that
you'd like to share to other people
here in the firm learning community let
me know your tips in the comment section
and as you know i will do my very best
to answer every single comment that you
write if you took away any value at all
out of this video please smash the like
button for the youtube algorithm and
also subscribe to my channel to stay up
to date on all my content if you want to
see even more from me follow me on my
instagram
and recently also started to become more
active on twitch
and on tiktok so you find links to both
of these platforms below
in the video description so check this
out now i also want to give a shout out
to all the members of firm learning
thank you so much for supporting me for
your contribution for this channel this
is really making a difference and if you
want to become a member as well and
benefit from some member
only perks hit the join button next to
the subscribe button to learn more about
this this is heinle from from learning
i'm releasing weekly videos every single
saturday here on my channel
so looking forward to see you again next
saturday until then good weekend to all
of you this is heimlich bye